let me first start with you know
remarking that the title of this
presentation is provocative and I don't
really mean it devops isn't that
platform engineering and devops are
actually best friends but wouldn't you
agree makes for a great title
now
I think one of the things that we have
to acknowledge is that cloud native is
dirty it's chaotic it is complex and
developers just waste a lot of time
operating apps and trying to make sense
on how things fit together
and if we think about
um
the applications that we operated 10
years ago there were a lot simpler they
had less global scale less distribution
less users monoliths less tools
everything is becoming much more complex
and I don't think that this is because
we just like like to procure new stuff
or try out new technologies which is
often used as a reason I think it's
because the world we live in and the
amount of users we serve is global is
complex in itself and our applications
need to meet that demand of an Ever
evolving ever more complex
um yeah
globalization really
now I always
um
think that this is the core point of all
of this and this is why I want to
emphasize this again and say that not
devops is dead that will probably remain
to be the philosophy or concept and The
Guiding Star as long as we are building
software but you build it you run it at
all cost
that is dead and it will not deliver
results and in fact it will lead to that
burn out of your teams
now
um the answer to I think that is
platform engineering platform
engineering if you want is the is the
implementation of good practices of
devops to a certain extent
now
um let's look at a little graph here the
um the pink curve is a proxy for cloud
native adoption in the end is just you
know container adoption that I believe
is a good proxy
and the yellow curve is the right rise
of internal developer platforms and
platform engineering
now if you if we go back a little bit in
time
16 years by now
um we have a noteworthy presentation by
Lana fogels who I think still is the CTO
at Amazon web services and he proclaimed
this you build it you run it
now if you think back 2006 the you build
it you run it applications that we just
discussed were a lot more simpler than
the ones that we are confronted with
today and that means in the context of
the time that claim of anaphor was made
a lot of sense yes you build it you run
it is is a good idea but as I just
suggested Cloud native has become a lot
more complex and um that means as
there's Cloud native trend
evolves we're seeing more and more teams
look at this and say hmm this can't be
the answer we're actually overwhelming
people we're not helping them we're
making things we're just throwing stuff
at them we're making things more and
more complex
and then in 2011 there is cloud native
at Google and as they're observing oh
things are getting more and more complex
they start with actually building uh
platforms and rolling them out at scale
and you can see that five-year lag
function from cloud native to hey we
need to change this in a lot of
different teams
um salando in Europe GitHub in
um in in in the United States where
Jason Warner moves over from Heroku
after being their senior as president
becoming the CTO at
um GitHub and then starting to build an
internal Heroku based on Amazon web
services
and that five-year lag function holds
true in almost every organization that
I'm um that I'm observing after five
years they're saying oh you know it's
not as easy after all
um let's not forget that you know
kubernetes on eks everyone has taken the
Amazon world has been around since I
don't know three four years so it's
still very fresh and so now more and
more teams are saying okay this this
can't be the truth we have to simplify
this and this is why platform
engineering is picking up so rapidly you
know it's not because Gartner made it a
top trend for 2023 no
gotten I made a top 10 for 2023 because
it's a response to that complexity that
we are currently um confronted with yeah
that's why everybody is speaking about
platform engineering and that's why
we're here today
now
what is platform engineering you know
why do we build these platforms well I
think in the end it's about
being fair towards different parts of
the organization you know let's look at
the platform uh at the application
developers and then the platform
operations SRE teams
um for the application developers is
really about reducing waiting times
reducing cognitive load making things
easier to consume enabling self-service
making it really simple to change
configurations effectively making it
really simple to
um
request an S3 bucket without having to
you know learn yet another technology or
you know maybe you can even you're
you're good at terraform but you just
don't want to you want to focus on the
application hand you're just not trying
to understand how that particular
networking is now implemented
I think it's very important that we want
to achieve all of that without
um abstractions the developer we
shouldn't go back into a world that we
had in
2014 2015 where you know we had these
platforms and there were black holes and
you had no idea what would happen under
the hood if you would send a certain
command so modern platforms are golden
paths opaque abstractions we want to
reach this but while not taking away
context if you think about a team like a
Google at a Google you you say hey I
need um
I need a certain
resource component and then the system
will say okay what's your context ah
you're deploying like a change of that
app to that environment well I'm going
to match you that resource
and that feels like okay Central Google
streams are deciding which resource to
match but they're actually very very
good at giving you the context hey you
know we're choosing this resource and
this is the way it's configured because
of ABC and if you don't apply a change
then that's the team you can speak with
or you can actually apply that change
yourself if you want to go deeper so I
call that layered abstractions let the
user decide what cognitive load they
want to expose themselves with
now the second team that actually
touched by this is obviously the
operation team platform team SRE team
depending on what latest bus world
you're using and for them it's really
about standardization by Design and
frankly reducing repetitive tasks I
think it's a good time to look at
platform engineering if you have a jira
board
um
that is
flowing over with hey can you help me
debug this and hey I need a new
environment here and at this point
platform engineering might be something
to look at
reduce ticket ops and then actually
allow these teams to focus to frankly
hit their SLA and improve the things
that there are and practices they're
using right now
what's an internal developer platform
well it's pretty simple
um it's the sum of many components that
form golden paths for developers there
is no not the IDP
um an IDP and that's for many people
frustrating that want to have easy
answers to complex questions and IDP for
a healthcare provider in
um
in in South Africa might look very
different to the financial services
company in Norway or the e-commerce
company in in San Francisco
but it's really about making sure you
have reusable components you wire all
your Dev tools and orchestrate them in a
structured manner you allow the
development team to consume that
um with low cognitive load and you allow
the platform engineering team to
automate that to actually reduce human
interaction and that in combination
actually helps you operate the
infrastructure in a repeatable manner
now I'm I'm from Germany so I obviously
uh need to think about cars all the time
and
um I have this analogy with a car
manufacturing industry immature
organizations tell teams to build a car
give them a credit card and then tell
them where to find a store with raw
materials and then when they struggle
they're sending people to help them
organize and then you call that devops
now mature organizations tell teams to
build a car give them a credit card and
tell them where to find the raw
materials if teams struggle devops helps
them organize and Cloud operations team
help them find the right materials and
prep those for them
and then Advanced organization tell
teams to build a car the platform team
prepares a platform developers build on
top and devops helps them structure
their work
and if you think about this and that's
something that Jason Warner said
um and that resonated a lot with me in a
good setups in a good setup developers
and operations do not talk about
transactional things they speak about
how can we improve the process how can
we make work easier and less
interruptive for all parts involved
um but they don't speak about hey uh can
you please spin up that environment
because that just leads to waiting time
and not actually produces every any
tangible value and outcome
but that's you know all good and fine
congratulations yet another uh category
hello platform engineering but where do
you actually get started with platform
engineering and you know I've been
fortunate enough to help a number of
organizations at this point on their
Journey towards platform engineering and
there is a certain Playbook
that I've been picking up and um you
know to a certain degree a step-by-step
guide and that will help you digest or
dissect how um to actually approach
platform engineering
as a first step I think it's really
about making sure you treat your
platform as a product
um
because
a platform and an internal developer
platform looks so different and no
matter in what organization you look
into there is no one-size-fits-all and
there is no recipe that you can look up
on Reddit that will just allow you to
get that as a sensible default you need
to shape this into and you tailor that
to the situation that you find yourself
in you will have different CI
pipelines and you will run different
types of workloads and all of that needs
to be mirrored within the platform
now
um I think then it's also important to
understand that depending on your
industry you will have completely
different governance requirements
security requirements it's a difference
whether you work in you know the U.S
government sector or in e-commerce
framework in
um you know a basement of a Berlin
hipster startup
now
um if we speak about platform as a
product what we mean is that yeah you
should treat it as a product you know
assign a product owner maybe you can't
afford somebody for a full-time
but it's a side project for one of your
POS they should have a you know clear
road map and grad tickets and or
whatever other project management tool
you're using
um they should
um you know a platform team has software
Engineers that can actually build stuff
you do user interviews you have a user
right it's an internal user but it's a
user there's nothing you know used as a
user you
um should do user interviews you should
measure whether your user likes your
platform and you need to do things step
by step by step you know and really see
that Above So number one and which
sounds trivial but not enough platform
engineering teams do that make sure you
treat your platform as a product manual
pays and Matthew skeleton have said that
for you know years
um but it's so vital so important I
really make sure that this is the way
you you approach and three things now
number two prioritization I think
many teams fall into that prioritization
fallacy where
they're you know they're letting
themselves be guided by feelings on what
to do first the the most obvious thing
is they they think about you know what's
the first thing a developer does when
they join a company well and they think
oh well they're on board well let's
actually start with making it really
simple for developers to onboard another
um behavioral pattern that I'm observing
is that they say well what's the first
thing that that we do when we start a
new application or service
and then the answer is well we're you
know starting a new service let's say
you know
um a uh spring boot service we'll take a
template and then we'll clone and then
we'll start to customize that
and just because that is the first thing
you do with an application but they
actually end up building as a really
simple way to start and build a new
microservice
it that might make sense in specific
situations but I mean ask yourself how
often do you actually onboard colleagues
how often do you actually spin up a new
service
and if you even if you do that very
often
how much time does that take you and
even if it takes you a long time isn't
there a lot of other stuff that's less
obvious and that's less anchored in your
brain that takes a lot more time and a
lot more interactions from developers
and operations thus actually
providing a lot of a lot more Roi return
on investment to the actual
um case so the first things you think of
if you think about platforms and what
you could optimize and you know really
things that go beyond the simple update
of an image well the first things you
think about don't necessarily need to
reflect the things that you should
actually Focus your attention on if you
start on your platforming journey
I always propose the same procedure on
how to actually
approach this now take a wide piece of
paper
sit down ask yourself well how often do
you go beyond the simple update of an
image and don't ask that yourself let me
correct myself ask that we're users your
individual front-end developers and your
back-end developers and your you know
operation teams and juniors and seniors
make sure to speak um to a couple of
them how often are they adding
environment variables how often do they
change configurations how often do they
spin up a new environment how often do
they onboard new colleagues then
normalize that so against 100
deployments how often do they do that
individual action how much time is
included for from developers how much
time is included per individual action
for operations teams and then you know
sum this up multiply that with your
total number of deployments and you have
your Roi case you know then just look at
what's the largest number of hours that
we spend as a company on those specific
things and here you go you have your
prioritization make sure you do that
exercise don't just think you can sense
that from your own experience very
unlikely you can
step number three agree on the lowest
common denominator Tech stack
it's unlikely that you can churn out
something that suddenly works for
everything
you know if you say you know you both
you you find yourself building a very
long stack of everything you need to
support
yeah you will probably not be able to
ship any product anytime soon and
who knows whether you still have your
funding if you can't actually provide
um you know tangible results fairly
quickly so
look at what's the most used thing or
what does the future hold you know is
the future VM or is the future
[Music]
um kubernetes or is the future
[Music]
um Lambda functions you know I don't
particularly care but you should find
your lowest common denominator and then
start optimizing against this in most
cases it will be containers and
kubernetes but you know everybody's
individual maybe it's
um
you know it's it's a it's a managed
service of one of the providers just
make sure you don't try to do everything
at once
number four you want to find your I call
it a lighthouse app a lighthouse team
one team of people that are really
Innovative that want to try new things
that are the ones that are always front
and center if it's you know if there's
something new to try that are really
interested in in doing this providing
feedback testing stuff and they should
have an application that's exactly on
your lowest common denominator Tech
stack
take that team right and then work with
that team uh very closely
as a Next Step
decide about the general architectural
layout we are seeing two patterns
trending
Dynamic internal developer platforms and
static internal developer Platforms in
the end it comes down to the methodology
of configuration management that you
choose and apply static configuration
management or dynamic configuration
management this here the the one that
we're seeing right now is a static IDP
so you have your IDE to code then you
have static config files in your version
control system
your workload yaml files on an
environment by environment basis
infrastructure as code and you have your
CI and Registries to actually build the
workload and then you throw everything
at a
CD at a controller and then stuff gets
deployed so that's the approach with
static
um configuration management and the
general architecture that's I would say
the most
common approach but also the I wouldn't
call it outdated but the you know
probably less
less modern or less flexible approach
the second approach that we're seeing
develop really fast and quickly now is
dynamic idps dynamic configuration
management that's the idea of layered
abstractions still the same progression
you have your IDE to code and then in
your
git you have a number of different files
you have your workloads you have a
workload specification that describes
the environment in an agnostic way so
one file that works across all
environments and there is an open source
project called score that is dealing
with exactly that and workloads and
workload specifications are the
the two things that developers usually
deal with so they say hey this is my
workload depends on a database of type
postgres rather than saying hey on that
particular RDS instance it's just in an
abstract way and then that request from
the developers get matched by with the
platform or operations
um sensible defaults if you want so the
platform team can say well if the
context is staging then please match
that particular RDS or create that DNS
and
there are still normalcy pipelines to
build the workload and then there's a
workload a platform orchestrator where
you basically read that declarative
application model and then say well
where am I okay environment of type
staging I'm going to create the actual
config files context specific I'm going
to mesh the infrastructure or I'm going
to create new ones and then I'm
orchestrating the workloads resources
and provide us the beauty is that the
developer can decide how deep do I want
to go how much come cognitive load do I
want to take it's a clear separation of
responsibilities of death and Ops
without getting in their ways and and it
drives your standardization by Design so
those are the key patterns there is
really like if you've gone down One path
you could still change that but I would
say you know think about this before you
start building
yeah then start building uh I believe
again platform as a product
small changes make sure you build the
one thing that matches your return on
investment think of the calculation that
we did before and makes it 10x better
even if it's only a small tiny thing
but you want to make sure that your
evangelist team loves it and thinks oh
this is so much better than everything
we have before over allocate time on
this it's the small little details that
really uh make your early fans
um and then
um you can take that those ambassadors
if you want and you can start
um scaling this to the next teams
actually expand your usage look at the
next things that actually provide Roi
never forget that there is no there is
no platform that's ready it's constantly
evolving once you've reached a certain
point there will be a new technology to
weave in so iterate iterate iterate
um and I encourage you to get help and
exchange thoughts with fellow platform
Engineers there's
platformengineering.org platform con as
a conference there are the meetups
there's the slack group and um yeah I
hope you make the most out of it and uh
you enjoy your journey such an exciting
time if you want to chat about this
again you know reach out to me Casper at
qnitech.com and until then thank you for
listening to this talk and see you soon